COLMAN MADDEN: Hi, everyone.
My name is Colman
Madden, and I'm
an engineer with Google
Cloud in New York focused
on asset management in
the hedge fund industry.
Prior to Google, I spent
around 10 years working
in the data engineering space.
I'm also here with
David Li from BlackRock,
whom I've been collaborating
with since early 2019.
David, over to you.
DAVID LI: Thank you, Colman.
Hi, my name is David.
I work in the financial
modeling group at BlackRock.
The group consists of a
team of engineers, modelers,
and researchers working
together to develop best
in class analytics to clients.
Today's agenda is as follows.
I'll first introduce
what we do at BlackRock,
then present two
use cases of how
we generate signals
using natural language
processing on Google Cloud.
First, I'll talk a
little bit about how
we train against returns to
construct a bespoke dictionary
to analyze sentiment
for single issuers
in the structured credit space.
Second, I'll talk about
knowledge graphs and entity
linking, and about how we
trained an entity linking model
to build a foundation for
constructing knowledge graphs.
In addition, I'll
talk about some use
cases for these concepts.
Colman will then conclude
with forward-looking views
of how to conduct investment
research on Google
Cloud in the future.
I lead a team inside FMG
called advanced data analytics.
Our responsibilities
span engineering,
financial modeling, and
natural language processing.
For data engineering,
we process data
sets that are terabytes
in size to extract insight
by leveraging big data
technologies such as Spark.
Some of our work have
been previously presented
at Spark Summit East.
We also leverage
managed services
provided by public clouds.
Our goal is to efficiently
deliver data driven solutions
to our clients.
As a team, we have a
wide range of skills
and provide flexible, end to
end solutions to streamline
future engineering, the
building of financial models,
and productionization.
Our approach to natural language
processing is a little bit more
focused on research.
We pay a lot of attention
to recent developments
in the applications of
text classification,
information extraction, and
entity linking in an NLP space.
The first use case
is classifying text
in a structured credit market.
In the past decade or so, the
leveraged loans market size
has been increasing.
Also, due to private nature
of these investments, publicly
available structured data sets
may be common, but sparse.
Taking a bottoms-up
approach, we analyze credit
at the issuer level.
We aim to tackle the problem
with future engineering
to add more insight
to the model, which
is to look at issuer defaults
and measure probability
of default from an issuer.
At the beginning of the year,
the US leveraged loans market
was around $1.2 trillion.
More than half of that is the US
collateralized loan obligations
market, which is
close to $700 billion.
In the past two
years, we've seen
record issuances of close
to $120 billion per year
in 2018 and 2019.
This increased
market size, coupled
with companies
assuming more debt,
give rise to additional
risk in the market.
At the same time, risks are
becoming increasingly difficult
to capture.
For example, environmental
changes such as COVID
had significant impacts to
the competitive landscape
in multiple sectors
such as retail.
As the political landscape and
regulatory oversight changes
over time, companies are exposed
to increased uncertainty.
Additionally, they're also
held to higher standards.
Companies are now
facing mounting pressure
on environmental,
social, and governance.
In order to address
these issues and capture
additional information
from alternative data sets,
we turn to natural
language processing.
We analyze large volumes
of textual news via NLP
to classify text
into sentiment scores
as well as other metrics such
as news volume and emotions
in these articles.
Some of the challenges in
predicting issuer probability
of default, or PD, over
some time horizon are,
first, it's typically difficult
to find structured data
on issuers due to
their private nature.
In these instances of where
data is actually available,
it can still be
subject to sparcity,
such as pricing data, due
to these instruments lacking
in liquidity.
Trying to apply NLP
to this problem,
available news
corpora are typically
at least terabytes in size,
and can easily exceed petabytes
across multiple periods.
Given these, we need both
persistence and compute
resources to be flexible,
whereas they typically
are constrained in a
fixed computation farm.
Thus we need a
flexible environment
to iterate and test our ideas
so we can extract and classify
text for predicting
probability of default.
Let's take a look at the
modeling process here.
First, we start off
with loading the data.
Then we apply transformations
such as tokenization stemming,
named entity recognition,
and sometimes even
applying language
models to reason
about text in the
embedding space.
Then we align unstructured
text with structured data sets
such as returns or spreads.
This step has to
be done carefully
to match market open
and close times as well
as time zones, and ways to
deduplicate articles that
discuss the exact same thing.
Once this is done, we query
the data stored and train
and evaluate our ideas by
tuning our hyperparameters
and finding thresholds
to construct
an optimal bespoke
sentiment dictionary.
Then we intuitively
roll this dictionary
across time for inference.
This process has proven to be
quite straightforward on Google
Cloud.
We start off by persisting
various stages of our data
to Cloud Storage, which is a
highly available distributed
store that gives us
plenty of scratch areas
to test our ideas.
Then we provision Dataproc
clusters with GCloud
in Cloud Console.
This provides us with an
ephemeral Hadoop Spark compute
cluster across our
large data sets.
An auto-scaling policy
and preemptible machines
are your best friend when
managing these clusters.
Recent metrics demonstrate
that Spark 3 performance
on Kubernetes is
catching up to YARN.
This is good news as we
could then potentially
switch to Spark
operators in the future.
After that, we leverage BigQuery
to run analytical workloads
and extract and filter
relevant information.
BigQuery has similar
functions as Hive,
storing metadata on
[INAUDIBLE] Compute Engine.
However for BigQuery, there's
no tuning or configuration
involved.
It automagically
handles your workloads
and produces results quickly.
Finally, we use AI
notebooks and Cloud Storage
as a combination to iterate
over our training and evaluation
cycle.
These managed notebooks
give us the flexibility
to scale our resources up and
down through configuration
changes.
Usually operating
on premise, we need
to be very careful about
resource consumption as well
as capacity planning due
to the multi-tenancy nature
of our shared compute clusters.
Typically, a single ETF job
that we've previously done
can take up to about an
hour when we have thousands
of these jobs running.
On Google Cloud, after
carefully configuring our setup,
we're able to compact
that time per iteration
down to two hours for
the entire data set.
Armed with scalability
and flexibility
to change the cluster size as
well as the type of cluster,
we can iterate on
multiple tests and focus
more of our time on
ideation and modeling
as opposed to worrying about
whether we're consuming
too much compute resources.
Some lessons we learned
during this exercise--
Spark, the de facto open source
big data processing tool,
is great for ETL on
disk I/O intensive jobs.
For large-scale
optimization calculations--
not so much.
We turn to distributed compute
frameworks such as Dask and Ray
for parallelizing these
optimization tasks
to optimize our runtime--
or to minimize our runtime.
Let's switch gears
to our second topic.
This one is more
exploratory in nature
and has received increased
attention in the past few years
in the research community.
We explore the applications of
entity linking and knowledge
graphs in the equity space.
We want to extract information
from the correct securities.
Moreover, we want to
track and identify
relationships between entities.
So we need entity
linking to map text
to an entity in
some knowledge base.
Some examples of applications
are extracting and analyzing
supply chain impacts
to companies, revenues,
and expenses.
Think of Foxconn
manufacturing iPhones.
Additionally, Samsung is a
supplier of screens for Apple.
Therefore, understanding
correlation
of performance between companies
due to their sheer dependencies
on the same suppliers
help us better
build equity risk models.
Similarly, we can analyze
corporate structure
such as ownership
in subsidiaries.
And here we define
ownership kind of loosely.
We analyze this to gain insight
how performance of one company
affects another.
Lastly, we were talking
about ESG before.
Creating models and measuring
corporate governance can
be aided with calculating the
diversity of boards, experience
and expertise of board members,
and how a member's track
record may affect the company
performance that they sit on.
On the right-hand side,
you can see a snapshot
of a personal knowledge graph.
It shows the ownership relations
of BlackRock as well as Google.
And the two companies
are connected
through Alphabet, which is
the parent company of Google,
and in which
BlackRock owns shares.
To construct a knowledge
graph, a fundamental step
is to look at the problem
of entity linking or EL.
Here's a simple example
given a sentence,
"Larry, whom we as the
chairman and CEO of BlackRock,
said, at the
beginning of the year,
that BlackRock would
place sustainability
at the center of the investment
approach at the firm."
In this example, it's
relatively easy for humans
to understand that "Larry"
refers to Laurence T. Fink, who
is the CEO of BlackRock.
And BlackRock is the
investment management company.
For a model, the difficulty
lies in training a system that
can correctly link
text bands to entities
that live in some knowledge
base such as Wikipedia.
The objective of
ELs is as following.
Give it a piece of text
recognized as [INAUDIBLE]
and link entities to an entry
defined in some knowledge base.
We use BERT as our
language model--
BERT was developed by
Google AI in 2018--
and a knowledge base that's a
mix of Wikipedia other sources.
In this case, we use Iago.
Our task is to detect mentions
and disambiguate entities.
Looking at this problem, we
need to provision resources
that can scale
with our workload,
namely, deliver us
GPUs for training
of large neural networks.
The productionization
process of these models
have typically been complex.
And we show how we can use
Google Cloud to achieve this.
Looking at the following
high-level architecture,
we can see that connecting
BlackRock and Google
networks through
interconnect and keeping
the traffic between the data
centers is a good way to start.
With a remote interpreter on
a virtual machine instance
on Compute Engine,
we're able to test
different types of
configurations of GPUs and TPUs
and tune them for training.
We then set up a
request server to run
evaluation on a local machine,
and then forward the port.
Lastly, we deploy our models
through TensorFlow serving
to expose the entity linking
model to clients through an API
through cloud endpoints.
This end to end
approach allowed us
to quickly iterate,
and train our models,
and minimize the deployment time
of our models to production.
Next, I'll hand
it over to Colman
to give a forward-looking
view of investment research
at Google Cloud.
COLMAN MADDEN: Thanks, David.
So David covered
two great use cases
where his team has been
leveraging GCP at BlackRock.
And I wanted to talk
a little bit more
broadly on how the
investment industry is
partnering with Google Cloud.
I don't think it's any secret
that the buy side is becoming
increasingly dependent
on data and AI
to power investment decisions.
And you'll see that by looking
at some of the statistics
here on the right-hand
side of the slide.
At Google Cloud, we
believe this aligns
really well with our powerful
analytics platform and the AI
research coming out
of Google Brain,
which we provide
to our customers
through our Cloud platform.
Why don't we start by looking
at a typical investment decision
flow for a buy side firm.
So firstly, formulate
an investment idea.
Source data to prove
out that hypothesis.
Generate signals from the data.
Construct the portfolio.
Backtest the portfolio.
Present the findings.
And determine a
capital allocation
from an investment committee
before moving into production.
The blue box highlights
the stages of process
we feel are a great
fit for Google Cloud.
So why run investment
research on Google Cloud?
Firstly, to provide the ability
for investing teams to spin up
projects quickly
and react to events
in the market in
an agile fashion.
Two, streamline the
onboarding of new data sets
from commercial data vendors,
such as Refinitiv and CME Group
through our data marketplace.
Three, burst compute
workloads into the cloud,
and eliminate
resource contention
from on-prem compute firms.
Four, get access to the latest
AI research through our APIs
and managed services.
And five, orchestrate your ML
workflows with state-of-the-art
DevOps and MLOps platform.
So how do we do all
this on Google Cloud?
Here's the high-level
architecture
of how firms are running an
investment research on GCP.
We start off by looking
at the blue box.
This is our data
acquisition project
where the data
engineering teams onboard
various data sets such
as market, portfolio,
news data, et cetera.
And if we look at the green
and yellow boxes below,
this is where the research
teams are using their tools
to access the data sets above.
We understand
there's often a wall
between different
investment teams.
And we can implement this
using our identity and access
management tools while
still allowing access
to shared resources
such as ticket stream.
So let's dive into
the GCP products
that sit behind these boxes.
In the data
acquisition project, we
can ingest streaming data
via our PubSub message queue,
or land files in
Google Cloud Storage,
trigger load jobs into BigQuery
or NoOps data warehouse.
Dataflow and Dataproc
are available for ETL.
We're also seeing a lot of
customers moving to an ELT
architecture where they load
the data as quickly as possible
and then use the power of
BigQuery to actually do
that transformation
using AntiSQL.
The data marketplace
allows data publishers,
aggregators to share their
data sets with financial firms
without the need for any ETL.
This is extremely valuable,
as data sets are often
in the petabytes.
You may have seen we just
announced BigQuery Omni, which
will enable firms to query
the data on AWS or Azure
from a single interface without
any cross-cloud movement
of our copies of data.
We push the compute to the data.
In the research projects,
quantitative researchers
can run simulations
on HPC clusters
with hundreds of thousands
of cores, custom VMs
that perfect the ratio
of cores to memory.
If your workflow can handle
preemptions and needs
to run for less than 24
hours, preemptible VMs
allow you to do this
at an 80% discount.
We just launched
confidential VMs,
which allow you to encrypt
data during processing,
and even when it's in memory.
So moving to the right,
our Cloud AI platform
allows quantitative researchers
to create AI notebooks
with the latest
TensorFlow, PyTorch,
and scikit-learn images
on CPUs, GPUs, or TPUs,
and pull this data--
these data sets straight
into Pandas DataFrames.
AutoML allows you to create
machine learning models
for natural language, structured
data translation without having
to write any code.
These models can be
trained to understand
terminology that is specific
to the financial services
industry.
Our Document AI
solutions enable you
to process complex financial
filings and earnings
reports with cutting-edge
NLP and transfer
learning technologies.
AI pipelines is built on
top of Kubeflow and TFX
and provides an MLOps solution
to evaluate, train, and deploy
machine learning
models to production.
These models can be shared
with other research teams
through AI Hub.
One really important
thing to note
here is that this is all
deployed by infrastructure
as code using something like
deployment manager or terraform
scripts.
So how do you get started?
So step one, you want to get
the cloud foundations in place.
Understand your requirements
around networking, security,
access management.
Wrap these up in
infrastructure as code.
And feed these into your
project creation pipeline.
Secondly, you want to understand
the process for onboarding
new data sets and build
a data acquisition
pipeline to automate this.
Thirdly, understand what
tools your researchers need,
and automate the
deployment of these tools,
along with the
connectivity they need
to access the data required
to run their experiments.
We want to make life
easier for everyone.
Thank you for coming
along to our talk today.
Please add any
questions to Dory.
Or feel free to reach out
to me or David directly.